this is the northernmost point in
Germany on the island of Zeus and it's
the starting point for Mikhail vagas
latest adventure his vehicle of choice
is a scooter originally designed for
younger adventurers and for short trips
over easy terrain we learn from notice
we want to travel the length of Germany
2,500 kilometers on cycle lanes and
paths if possible in 80 days Lucas in
oxy tagging we want to explore the
country and see what discoveries we can
make by the wayside I'm Vegas [ __ ] of a
figure she ended up an ambitious
undertaking which will kick off on zote
bigger plans to ride to the southernmost
point in Germany the 2473 kilometer
journey will take him all the way down
to Holland banger heck in Bavaria on the
border with Austria sadly he will not
have much time to enjoy the scenery the
roving reporter is also the cameraman
there's one camera attached to this
helmet and another at the end of his arm
he takes his first break after 13
kilometres house of peanuts couple have
been going for just under an hour now I
need to go for four hours a day at that
speed to stay on schedule it's pretty
demanding in terms of fitness and muscle
power the sitting posture means my
thighs have some building up to do no I
think it's almost got to live in that
hay KO bhi gaya has spent months gearing
up for this tour he's been doing
endurance training he stopped smoking
and switched to a healthy diet
shortly before Vegas sets off the Euro
max team follows him as he Braves DWS
impromptu weather simulator
and you'll also need the right equipment
for extreme conditions other yet these
are crucial mud guards on the front and
back o clock emotes leet good and lights
in case you're out in the evening not
far I'm fartin Vista Katrina of course
you need a scooter with front and rear
brakes but despite that I won't be
riding on public roads definitely gosh
pasa fun he'll be sticking mainly two
Psychopaths his scooter is fitted with a
navigation device to keep him on the
right route but Mikhail biggest tour is
not just about the sporting challenge
he's also keen to meet people do they
reckon he's going to make it in time I
don't think so nay does the multi thanks
for the confidence boost these are galfy
and fire deusex you say sure you say no
and you not to talk some people have
made it around the world in 80 days we
don't believe it but if you do make it
I'll buy you a drink maybe somebody
should have I give you a nose I'll take
you up on that great thank you for
making Vega has already embarked on two
previous trips around Germany for
euromaxx a sightseeing tour in an old
car for land of loveliness and in the
truth about Germany he played a cultural
explorer looking into cliches about
Germany and its people this expedition
is certainly the most athletic vigor
will be escorted by a camper van that
will also be his temporary home
lochwinnoch mrs. from the thing I like
most about these projects is the new
experience you're away from home and
your own bed you're in a totally novel
situation it's mine yeah you know I got
snoring ashish to thank mikaël vigor
will wind down after each day's
adventures by updating his travel log
it'll be published in book form in the
fall but vika is already imagining the
final scene that states me as alois
hosing triumphantly holding my scooter I
made it that's my aim at least shaft
with evolution feminist after day one
some two thousand four hundred
kilometers still separate mihail vigor
from his ultimate goal so until then he
has a long way ahead of him
you